في اغلى صفقه في العالم العربي حصلت شركه
روتانا للصوتيه مرئيه على حقوق استثمار
المصنفات والمحتوى الفني للفنان العرب
محمد عبده كتالوج الاغاني المؤرشفه اللي
استلمته روتانا بيضم 122 البوم وفي من بنى
اغاني يمكن يتم اعاده التسجيلها العقد
اللي تم توقيعه بين شركه الفنان الخاصه
صوت الجزيره وبين شركه روتانا ونتائج
تاريخ فنان العرب على مدى 60 عام وراح
تشرف روتانا على اداره المحتوى والاستفاده
منه بافضل طريقه المستشار التركي ال الشيخ
كان له كلمه خلال المؤتمر الصحفي اللي تم
الاعلان في عن الصفقه واللي اكد خلالها
على اهميه هذه الخطوه واهميه الارث الفنيه
الفنان محمد عبده ليس فنان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بس وابرز فنان في الوطن
العربي وابرز فنان في الشرق الاوسط من
الابرز في العالم
تاريخيا وانتاجيا وشهره
فالارشيف لشركه الخاصه اللي كانت بتسمى
شركه صوت الجزيره
انتقل بالكتالوج كامل للروتانا لاداره
المحتوى والاستفاده منه فيه كثير من
الفنانين الكبار احنا واجهنا صعوبه سواء
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وفي الوطن
العربي بعد عمر طويل او بعد اعتزالهم او
بعد الله يطول عمرك يا محمد يعني او بعد
اعتزالهم او بعد اي شيء
نواجه صعوبات ما عائلتهم او مع تقدير هذا
الارث الفني او الاستفاده منه الان الارث
هذا بشيء في ايادي امينه في شركه وطنيه
سعوديه تستفيد منه اللي يحب اقوله انه
برضه لا زال الفنان الكبير محمد عبده
لازال يحطوا كل الارقام القياسيه هذا اغلى
ارشيف اتباع انا ما راح اعلن الرقم
لارشيف فنان في تاريخ الشرق الاوسط ويمكن
من الاغلى في العالم
كلها كانت مخزنه ومحفوظه
لانه ظاهره التكنولوجيا جديده في همم في
القرن الجديد اللي هو 20 على راسها
روتانا اليوم
الوحيده التي تقدر هذا وتسمى هذا الشيء
وبدور على شركه روتانا عبر رئيسا سالم
الهندي شكرت الفنان محمد عبده على اختياره
لها واكدت انها راح تكون امينه على ارشيف
والفنيه
ابو ناصر مع المستشار تركي ال الشيخ
بصراحه كان هو يعني
عراب الصفقه هذه اللي صارت مع الفنان
العرب محمد عبده هذه الصفقه طبعا يعني همم
المحتوى الفني الثوري لفنان العرب في خلال
60 عام يعني انتقل الى شركه روتانا وان
شاء الله يعني احنا نكون امين على هذا
المحتوى
باذن الله يعني ان هذا المحتوى نحافظ عليه
احنا كمان اكبر شركه انتاج الوطن العربي
شركه السعوديه كمان فان شاء الله يا رب
الله يوفقنا
وطبعا من بعد ما تم الاعلان عن هذه الصفقه
كثير من الفنانين رتوه تغريده المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ اللي اعلن فيها عن توقيع
العقود وابره من الصفقه وتفاعلوا مع الخبر
واعتبروها خطوه مهمه للفن السعودي
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
من اترككم مع لمحه من التاريخ الاستثنائي
لمحبوب الفنان او المحبوب الملايين اللي
فنان العرب محمد عبده في امان الله
يا حبيبي
انا انا
استلم
ربي يتمم لنا انسانا
انسانا
يا حبيبي
[موسيقى]
انا
الليله عندي بسمه
[موسيقى]
هذا الامل عمري
امشي ما بسم
تي
[موسيقى]
وليله
بالامل عمري
وياربما كانت ولا اللي احساس
يا ريت الدنيا
خانتني وكل الناس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علي انا تعود
ريانه العود
ريانه
[موسيقى]
العود
ريانه العمر
امين
[موسيقى]
يا رب
عدنا
[موسيقى]
لل